und bei uns im studio ist jetzt
angemeldet der ukrainische botschafter
in deutschland und man muss wirklich
sagen ml nicht selten gab es einen
botschafter der sein amt so ausgefiltert
der tatsächlich ein botschafter seines
landes ist schön dass wir wieder bei uns
sind sie haben gerade erzählt dass sie
etwas verspätet waren weil sie noch ein
telefonat geführt haben mit dem
auswärtigen amt können sie uns darüber
berichten ja das stimmt ich hatte eine
einzige bitte an die kollegen hier in
berlin in der ampel der regierung wir
haben jetzt diese schrecklichen bilder
gesehen wo häuser bombardiert werden in
einem ausmaß wo
fast harmlos aussieht und das erleben
wir tag und nacht und nicht nur an einem
ort gedanke der gesamten frontlinie und
deswegen brauchen wir eine
flugsverbotszone
die über den großstädten errichtet
werden sollte aber auch über dem größten
kernkraft wert in europa internet von
sabrina das wurde auch jetzt besetzt von
den russen und wir haben jetzt keine
kontrolle wir haben die weltgemeinschaft
darüber informierte und erlernt locken
stellen deswegen ist geht es darum dass
das team nato-partner eine kreative
lösung finden morgen wird darüber
gesprochen in brüssel das dass der
luftraum endlich geschützte wird damit
die zivilisten nicht sterben müssen
unter diesem regen hagel das kann man
gar nicht ertragen sie haben ja bei uns
in der sendung des öfteren schon
warnungen appelle abgegeben sie haben
vor allem die letzten wochen auch immer
nach waffen gebeten nach
verteidigungswaffen jetzt sind sie da
seit gestern die meldung dass die
deutschen waffen auch in der ukraine
angekommen sind wie sehr helfen diese
waffen den menschen vor ort jetzt also
wir sind erleichtert dass diese
entscheidung ähnlich viel nach langem
zögern aber jetzt kommt es darauf an
dass wir diese ersten schritte
fortsetzen
die ersten raketen anti panzer raketen
und boden luft raketen sind angekommen
endlich endlich sind sie da aber jetzt
versuchen wir und wir haben auch heute
eine neue aktualisierte liste von von
waffensystemen an die bundesregierung
übermittelt wo es jetzt darum geht dass
wir so viel viel mehr bräuchten und zwar
nicht nur von der bundeswehr wir wissen
dass auch da natürlich sehr viel
aufgerüstet werden müsste sondern auch
von der deutschen industrie und wir sind
jetzt gerade die letzten tage in sehr
intensiven gesprächen jetzt kommt es
darauf an was bedeutet in diesem in
dieser situation wo
zivilisten in diesem ausmaß bombardiert
werden was ist jetzt eine defensiv waren
wir haben noch vor kurzem darüber hier
gestritten und einige generelle wie herr
kujat gesagt hat dass ein anti panzer
rakete auch eine offensiv war für sein
kann jetzt ist es so dass ein panzer
wahrscheinlich auch eine defensiv waffe
sein könnte wenn es darum geht ein dorf
von von von einem konvoi zu schützen
oder eben eine drohne abzuschießen das
heißt dieser liste jetzt eine eine ganz
andere liste es geht uns darum dass
panzer gepanzerte wagen vielleicht auch
flugzeuge oder schiffe geleitet werden
können denn es geht um das schiere
überleben für uns defensivwaffen es sind
also verteidigungswaffen und in der tat
sie verteidigen sich sie greifen nicht
an das ist genau der punkt in diesem
moment hermeling nach unseren
informationen finden wieder
verhandlungen statt delegation aus
russland und der ukraine sitzen jetzt
zusammen es sind keine hochrangigen
delegation also beispielsweise
außenminister die daran teilnehmen was
es trotzdem von diesen gesprächen zu
erwarten worum genau geht es
das ist die zweite runde
es ist wichtig dass man wieder ähnlich
spricht und wir haben eine ziemliche
hochkarätige delegation geschickt das
ist der verteidigungsminister
die können auch entscheidungen treffen
vor ort
denn es geht uns darum dass die
waffenruhe schnellstmöglich beschlossen
wir dann damit wir zwei drei tage haben
um die toten zu bergen um die verletzten
zu versorgen
um auch den gefangenenaustausch mal
einzuleiten es geht aber vor allem um
die menschen zu versorgen mit
lebensmitteln denn in großstädten wie
harte worte mariupol ganze im osten
dieser städte wurden seit tagen
bombardiert
abgeschnitten von stromversorgung werde
mir fehlt die menschen leben in kalten
kellern seite eine woche und das heißt
wir brauchen auch sogenannte humanitäre
korridore zu schaffen um diese menschen
zu versorgen oder dementsprechend auch
ihre evakuierung zu ermöglich wir sehen
gerade oben rechts im bild ein
klavierspieler managers sind bilder von
der ukrainisch rumänischen grenze dort
und wenn die kamera gleich wieder
aufziehen wird dann sehen wir da sind
sehr viele flüchtlinge also da ist ein
klavierspieler der für flüchtlinge
gespielt wir haben mal kurz zu
jetzt hat er gerade auf gehört natürlich
das ist hervor für effekt dann gibst du
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was geht ihnen vor wenn sie so weiter
sehen ja da muss man mit tönen gamble
[Musik]
also diese hilfsbereitschaft die jetzt
an rollt auch durch kleine gesten
einfach nur mein klavier aufzustellen um
den menschen einfach auch mut zu machen
ihnen hoffnung zu geben es ist jetzt
glaube ich in diesen stunden ganz ganz
wichtig für diese menschen die ohne
heimat sind auf einmal dort ankommen das
macht man sich vorstellen wir haben
innerhalb einer woche mindestens eine
million menschen die fliehen musste
nicht wollten sie mussten plänen in
syrien im süden krieg auch so grausam
war waren dass eine melone in zehn
jahren das heißt das ist die dimension
dieses angriffskrieges denn wir leben
und deswegen man darf diese menschen
nicht im stich lassen wir haben jetzt
auch seit tagen gebeten auch die
bundesregierung
eine versorgungs brücke zu schaffen eine
berliner luftbrücke
2.0 zu schaffen um eben diesen menschen
zu helfen die jetzt abgeschnitten sind
von versorgungswege wir haben bilder
gesehen bei alzheimer hat gerade heute
vormittag in
supermärkten und da sagen die regeln die
regale fast fass leer das heißt da muss
schnellstens gehandelt werden und
deswegen wir hoffen dass diese brücke
über dem landwege über polen und in die
ukraine geschaffen wird um die
zivilisten tatsächlich zu helfen ja das
ist dieses wirklichen bilder ja die und
die menschen gehen dadurch und ich finde
es auch bemerkenswert das ist mir in den
letzten tagen auch immer mehr
aufgefallen die menschen die dort noch
verblieben sind in kiew oder auch in
anderen großstädten sie sind unglaublich
ruhig fast schon in gewissermassen
gelassen weil sie haben gar keine andere
wahl mit dieser situation sonst
umzugehen das ist ja das sind
gänsehautmomente es gibt keine panik ist
es gibt keine keine überfälle auf
supermärkte auf lebensmittel lager das
ist also die menschen mehr als die
menschen versuchen die ruhe zu bewahren
das ist nicht einfach
man seit einer woche in der u bahn
erleben muss oder im keller eines
eigenen hauses aber aber wir wollen
trotzdem nicht aufgeben und schon gar
nicht kapitulieren dann es wird immer
wieder neu gelegt ja was könnte die
ukraine tun ja welche zugeständnisse ich
meine egal was wir tun oder egal was wir
jetzt was sie anbieten als kompromiss
also bot ihn geht es um alles möchte uns
einfach vernichten und deswegen es ist
an der zeit dass das dass die
bundesregierung auch diese zeitenwende
die haben am sonntag im bundestag
verkündet wurde zeitenwende deutlicher
stimme ovationen gekommen haben oben auf
der tribüne
das waren die ukraine ich habe das gar
nicht auf mich bezogen also diese diesem
moment aber vor allem auf die menschen
die so mutig sind so dafür sind die sich
vor die ganze für die rollenden banzer
stellen und die den weg von den konvois
behindern ohne waffen mit seiner fahne
die hymne singen also das sind momente
wo man wirklich sagte das kann doch
nicht sein dass man uns in berlin keine
chance eingeräumt auch am achten tag des
krieges ist es so dass wenn ich sage
immer frei von versorgungs brücke
weitere waffenlieferungen
dann
hat man das gefühl dass dass wir
tatsächlich ja schon abgeschrieben sind
weil gegen diese übermacht militärisch
betrachtet aus russland gibt es keine
verteidigung und ich sage immer wieder
das stimmt nicht man darf uns nicht
unterschätzen wir sind da wir kämpfen
der präsident ist nach wie vor im in
kiew er bleibt gibt mut den menschen und
deswegen ich kann mir gar nicht
vorstellen wie die ukraine diesen krieg
verlieren kann man man kann diesen krieg
von der putin angezettelt hat erkannten
den nicht gewinnen erkannte kann aber
nicht alle menschen aus dem land
vertreiben und so lansky der ukrainische
präsident sie haben es angesprochen hat
gesagt wenn sie hier sind und uns
besetzen wollen werden sie keine minute
in frieden leben das stimmt ich meine
man mag vielleicht bestimmte gebiete wie
wir sehen diese schrecklichen taten das
erinnert mich an
krebszellen die sich verbreiten
im organismus der ukraine aber glauben
sie mir es gibt sehr wechseln auch wenn
man dann vielleicht die ein oder andere
stadt besetzt oder oder vielleicht
einige dörfer oder oder straßen das kann
nicht auf dauer sein denn die menschen
werden
dagegen kämpfen auch wenn das einen
partisanenkrieg sein sollte wir hoffen
dass das nicht das so kommt die russen
sind nicht willkommen ich habe keinen
einzigen moment gesehen wo sowohl die
russischen truppen mit blumen da
begegnete sind sondern mit molotow
cocktails und das ist etwas was die
russen natürlich auch putin selbst kann
nicht so blind sein um das nicht zu
sehen sie sind weiterhin sehr
optimistisch was natürlich auch ein
wahnsinniges gutes signal ist für den
menschen da draußen darf ich sie fragen
wie ihr alltag momentan aussieht wie
sehr sich ihr leben persönlich auch
verändert hat seit kriegsbeginn und wie
sie sich schützen auch wenn sie
wahrscheinlich darüber wenig auskunft
geben möchten doch ich meine jetzt leben
wir in einer anderen sozialen welt auch
als familie oder als team hier als land
als regierung das betrifft uns alle ich
habe seit zwei tagen personenschutz und
und wir haben keine frühstück
mittagessen und abendessen das schläft
man ein paar
stunden vielleicht und das ist gut so
dass man wieder kraft hat weiter zu
kämpfen und wir werden den deutschen
nicht das geschenk machen dass wir
aufgeben dass das wir sagen ok hat sich
nicht gelohnt also dass das ist keine
option denn wenn wir uns ergeben dann
haben wir gehört also was dann auf die
ukraine vor allem auf die
zivilgesellschaft auf die aktivisten zu
kommen kzr schließungsliste was noch das
ist deswegen keine option entweder sind
wir standhaft und werden uns ab oder wir
gehen unter und das alleinige keine wahl
sie sind in lemberg geboren haben 25
jahre lang in kiew berufsbedingt gelebt
haben auch familie in kiew ihre
schwiegermutter glaube ich erzählten sie
beim letzten mal sie werden ja auch im
permanenten kontakt sein
was sind das für persönliche gespräche
die sie auch führen jedenfalls das sind
sehr schwere gespräche mein
schwiegervater bleibt nach wie vor in
kiew meine schwiegermutter und die nicht
die sechs nächte verbracht hat die sind
gestern sie haben gestern kirche
verlassen und die sind jetzt bei meiner
mutter in lemberg weil weil dann die
gefahr doch für sie zu hoch ist das sind
werte und dass das auch klappt jetzt so
massiv wie die vororte geschossen wird
mit der kette mit luftwaffe und glauben
sie mir da
da es ist schwer mit tränen zu kämpfen
wenn man mit ihnen spricht ja sie ist
mit einem koffer
gereiste und sie weiß nicht wann sie
nach kiew zurückgekehrt und mein
schwiegervater 1 267 hätte eigentlich
ausreichen können weil
müsste nicht jetzt in die armee
eingezogen werden wie manche andere aber
sagte nein also ich werde wenn schon das
westrussische dann muss ich in meiner
heimatstadt auch sterben das ist also
die stimmung sie haben gesagt ja da muss
man mit den tränen kämpfen das haben sie
vorher selber hier auch getan also dem
klavierspieler zugehört haben dort an
der
grenze wo viele flüchtlinge ankommen
vielleicht wollen wir zum schluss
unseres gesprächs haben einige vielen
dank für irgendwie suche einfach noch
mal ein bisschen rande
[Musik]
überall an an vielen grenzübergängen
herr männicke spielen sich
flüchtlingsdramen ab wir haben auch
bilder gesehen wie halt menschen die
geflohen sind dann von freunden oder
verwandten an der grenze auf der anderen
seite in den arm genommen werden das
sind herzzerreißende ist sehen natürlich
gleichzeitig auch eine große welle der
solidarität in diesem moment sind
zehntausende schüler beispielsweise auf
den straßen in deutschland
das hilft ihnen natürlich nicht in der
konkreten situation in der ukraine aber
was bedeutet ihnen sicher etwas doch das
hilft er sehr wohl heute waren einige
schulklassen vor unsere botschaft und
haben auch blumen gebracht und einfach
gehalten und das bedeutet das dass
dieses gefühl ja das ein
gewaltiger krieg mitten in europa top
der seit acht tagen dass dieses gefühl
auch hier in deutschland ankommt in den
familien und dass man
erkennt dass man sowas garnicht zu
lassen kann und das vielleicht auch die
dass die breite öffentlichkeit die sich
so stark solidarisch seite es kommen und
jetzt auch in berlin
tausende landsleute aus der ukraine sie
werden hier sehr herzlich willkommen und
da sind auch gästen die wirklich in
erinnerung bleiben dass das sie hier
aufgenommen werden dass sie auch
möglichkeit bekommen zu schlafen nach
nach tagelangen fahrten ohne ohne schlaf
ohne unruhe das sind wichtige momente
und ich glaube dass auch das etwas für
meine landsleute bedeutet dieses zeichen
der zuversicht dass das man hier
da ankommt weil bei freunden und
gleichzeitig hoffen wir und bitten auch
die die bundesregierung das mag
vielleicht
nicht unbedingt
so klingen als dass das nötigste ist
nämlich wir brauchen gleichzeitig auch
eine perspektive auch wie diese menschen
die flehen müssen auch für für diese
hunderttausende aber auch für diejenigen
die bleiben wir brauchen eine
perspektive und das heißt
eu mitgliedschaft ist etwas was mein
präsident mitten in diesem bunker wurde
jetzt bietet angeboten hatte und gebeten
hatte die bundesregierung wir hoffen
dass man uns auch zuhört ganz herzlichen
dank für eine besuch hier im studio und
auch ihre persönlichen eindrücke die sie
uns wieder gegeben haben